foreign
I saw this and this is you could put it
under impulse purchase you could put
under obsolete object I think it is both
but it is so tricky this is why
marketing is so enticing Ryan I'm gonna
show you this video that we have and
when I first saw this on Instagram it
showed up in my algorithm somewhere
it is a storage solution for people with
OCD like me oh wow okay and actually let
you know let's take a look at the video
if you're watching the video version of
the podcast you will see it otherwise
we'll come back and explain it here in a
moment let's take a look at the video
Ryan okay
oh my God all right so we're playing
this without sound it's a couple in
their garage and they're they have all
these totes that look really nice and
they're storing the totes on the ceiling
of their garage and it's nice and
organized and so Ryan as soon as I saw
this you can imagine what I thought how
do I get this immediately yeah that
looks
um it is very pleasing to my OCD I don't
even have OCD but and you see it and
it's like oh this is a solution wait a
minute this is a solution to a problem I
don't have because if I need this what
the heck am I going to put in these bins
I don't have anything to put in these
bins so I would also have to acquire
things to store in the bins I'd have to
acquire a garage because I don't have a
garage either that I would store these
things in but it made me think like oh
yeah I
was addicted to organizing and being
addicted to organizing is a type of
hoarding not my space now Ryan whenever
you come to my house it looks organized
but the easiest way to organize your
stuff
is to get rid of most of it yeah that
way I don't have to put it in bins in
fact if let's say when I bought the
house these whatever it was 16 bins were
installed here in my ceiling I would
have to look at it every day and say
what the heck am I supposed to put in
those yeah now maybe one or two of them
I could put a blanket or something in
but even then
it would be Superfluous for me I would
rather have the open space than to store
things in my garage because let's face
it let's say I have all 16 of those Ryan
or you have all 16 of those
how convenient is if I actually need to
get something from the fourth one back
yeah you have to take them all down and
then I have to sort through it oh you
know what it's not actually in that tub
it's in the tub next to it it's the next
row of storage bins yeah that was my
favorite thing when you sent this to me
the top comment at the time said if I
put those up there I'll never open them
ever again yes and that's what that's
what storage lockers count on right yeah
and so instead of having a storage
locker I get this is will save you some
money on the long run but you know how
else to save that money is by simply
getting rid of the excess things so you
don't need to store them yeah it is
a very unique solution it is a it is
like enticing it makes me think like oh
I could totally use that yeah yeah I get
it and that's why when we do this
impulse purchase segment or the obsolete
objects to me it's obsolete because
storage is obsolete for me personally
now but it's also an impulse purchase
because I saw this on Tick Tock or
Instagram wherever it was and I see it
I'm like oh wait a minute
I think I need wait why do I need that
and that's the problem with impulse
purchases we never stopped to ask
ourselves why do I actually need that
why do I want that and I will do this
all the time even with a jacket for
example or with anything that I feel the
the tug of consumerism I'm trying to
fill some sort of void that is going on
inside of me with external things to
complete me and of course I'm already
complete without the storage totes on on
my ceiling amen I would say those things
are just gonna get in the way for me did
you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free